mes collègues nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir ce matin devant
notre commission
monsieur Yannick Morez qui est alors le
maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
démissionnaires mais on entendait la
radio ce matin que vous avez le préfet
local avait les plus hautes pressions
pour ne pas accepter votre démission
c'est un poids de plaisanterie dans un
moment qui est difficile
qui est difficile pour vous
[Musique]
égard aux événements que vous venez de
subir à titre personnel et qui ont fait
que vous avez décidé de remettre votre
mandat vous avez en face de vous et à
côté de vous
d'abord à côté de vous madame Maryse
Carrère qui est sénatrice de Pyrénées
monsieur Darnaud qui est sénateur de
l'Ardèche qui sont tous les deux
actuellement en charge d'une mission sur
le devenir des communes et des maires
naturellement et puis les collègues ici
qui toussent un moment ou un autre ont
eu un mandat local
conseiller départemental de présidente
conseil départemental de maire nous
avons tous été un autre en
responsabilité c'est dire à quel point
la situation que vous avez vécue ou que
vous vivez nous l'avons connu pas
forcément de la même manière mais en
tous les cas nous avons conscience de la
situation aujourd'hui de nos élus de nos
collègues je précise de nos collègues
élus dans les communes et des instants
de violence et d'agression que vous
vivez
je ne suis pas là pour faire un
témoignage personnel mais ayant occupé
des fonctions de mer de ma commune dans
le Rhône pendant 20 ans j'ai connu des
moments
parfois un peu difficiles naturellement
comme nous tous mais très honnêtement
jamais à la hauteur de ce que les
collègues meurent aujourd'hui en durent
laquelle la violence elle est presque
dire quelle que soit les milieux est en
train de prendre sa place dans notre vie
publique dans notre vie tout court et à
quel point elle constitue je le crois
véritablement de plus qu'un danger et
doit être combattu et ce matin si vous
avez souhaité que vous puissiez venir
devant la commission des Lois du Sénat
c'est parce que depuis plusieurs années
maintenant outre le fait que le Sénat et
la chambre des collectivités locales et
particulièrement sensibles à ce qui se
passe
je salue entre la présence de Van Gatel
qui est membre de la commission des lois
mais qui est également présente de la
délégation collectivités territoriale
nous nous intéressons de près sur ce qui
se passe pour nos élus je ne rappellerai
pas
le lâche crime du maire de
signer je ne rappellerai pas ce que
vient d'ailleurs de dire une collègue
mère de Bretagne de Plougastel le
Plougrescant pardon qui a été victime
également d'agression et de tant
d'autres qui au coditiens au quotidien
sont l'objet de ces agressions donc
c'est notre intérêt d'abord de vous
apporter notre soutien je crois que je
peux le faire à l'unanimité de tous les
collègues présents ici mais c'est
l'intérêt aussi que vous veniez devant
la représentation nationale dire ce que
vous avez vécu parce que là du fait de
ce que vous allez dire nous voulons
comprendre
ce qui ne s'est pas passé
et en particulier nous avons lu dans vos
déclarations que vous avez attendu de un
soutien de l'État je le dis directement
tel qu'on l'a lu il faut que nous
comprenions précisément ce qu'il s'est
passé parce que
dans différents textes récents
que nous avons voté ici nous avons
souhaité
que les préfectures que les magistrats
soient proches des élus locaux des mers
en particulier alors écoute nous avons
légiféré sur ces points là
que par ailleurs nous avions saisi je me
souviens en 2019 début 20 et 2020 pardon
2021 pardon le garde des sceaux sur la
situation des élus il avait lui-même
répondu et pris des engagements
que j'ai à mon dossier
donc ce que vous allez dire n'est pas
pour être retenu contre vous mais
évidemment mais c'est surtout
pour comprendre ce que vous avez vécu ce
que vous n'avez pas pu obtenir pour que
nous puissions ensuite continuer
d'avancer dans ce travail de contrôle
qui est le nôtre et d'une part la
possibilité de faire peut-être améliorer
notre législation ou alors améliorer le
système voilà j'ai été beaucoup trop
long Monsieur le Maire parce que je vais
laisser la parole quelques instants à
Madame maïs Carrère puis ensuite à
vous-même pour
s'y témoigner en tous les cas merci de
votre présence ce matin
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues Monsieur le Maire je me
contenterai de quelques mots pour
rappeler les raisons qui nous conduisent
aujourd'hui à nous associer à la
commission des lois pour vous entendre
Monsieur le Maire nous associer aussi
aux propos du président buffet et vous
apportez tout notre soutien dans ces
moments qui pour vous mais aussi votre
famille sont sûrement pénibles et
douloureux dès le début de ces travaux
la mission d'information sur l'avenir de
la commune et du maire s'est intéressé à
la problématique des démissions
volontaires de mer dont on observe
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui en ce début de
mandat plus nombreuses que lors de la
précédente mandature et nous y avons vu
le symptôme d'un mal-être des mers dont
il nous appartenait d'identifier les
causes déjà au fil de nos édits de nos
auditions et de nos déplacements des
éléments émergent un sentiment d'abandon
un déséquilibre entre les charges que
l'on doit assumer et les moyens dont on
dispose et l'aide on reçoit et des
relations parfois plus tendues avec
certains citoyens et les causes sont
bien entendu nombreuses et nous avons
lancé depuis la semaine dernière une
vaste consultation Internet des élus
municipaux ouvertes jusqu'au 8 juin pour
recueillir leur point de vue sur les
conditions d'exercices de leur mandat et
leur perception de l'avenir de la
commune elle sera je n'en doute pas
riche d'enseignement et nous permettra
de mieux mesurer l'ampleur du phénomène
et des difficultés auxquelles les mères
sont confrontés mais ces statistiques
seraient bien sûr impuissantes à décrire
la réalité du phénomène si nous ne
disposions pas en même temps du
témoignage direct de ceux qui sont
confrontés à ces difficultés c'est
pourquoi Monsieur le maire au nom de mes
collègues de la mission d'information je
vous remercie d'avoir accepté de
témoigner devant nous afin de nous
éclairer sur le drame que vous avez vécu
et sur ce qui selon vous a manqué dans
l'aide et la protection que vous auriez
dû recevoir puis je laisserai peut-être
en suivant la parole au rapporteur pour
pour des questions suivantes
merci bonjour à tous d'abord je tiens
par commencer par remercier en fin de
compte tous les messages de soutien que
j'ai pu avoir de tous les élus de France
en quelque soit le rôle
ça apporte beaucoup de chaleur c'est
vrai
je me suis aperçu qu'en fin de compte
dans tous ces messages d'élus que j'ai
reçu j'ai reçu par rapport à la date de
l'incendie par rapport au 22 mars où
j'avais déjà reçu beaucoup de messages
de soutien beaucoup plus de messages
notamment de soutien de maire qui m'ont
exprimé également ce qui leur était
arrivé et notamment parfois les
agressions qu'elles soient verbale ou
physique et puis qui n'ont en fin de
compte n'ont rien fait non pas non pas
déposé plainte puisque à chaque fois
c'est ce qu'il me mettait dans les
courriers que j'ai reçu très souvent ça
terminait sans suite voilà donc en fait
c'est vrai que quand on voit le chiffre
important et notamment l'augmentation
importante des agressions depuis un an
je pense que ce chiffre est largement
sous-estimé si vous évaluez puisque dans
les dans tous ses courriers on
s'aperçoit quand même que c'est
relativement très souvent et puis c'est
vrai que je pense que c'est pas terminé
avec toutes les contraintes que nous
avons nous a subir les maires avec les
différentes lois et je pense que dans
l'avenir et notamment avec la loi climat
résilience et notamment avec le zan
on sait très bien qu'on a des des
personnes des des concitoyens qui ont
acheté parfois des terrains à
transmettre pour leurs enfants quand il
faudra leur annoncer que ces terrains ne
sont plus constructibles qui est-ce qui
va prendre ce sont encore les mers
donc dans un premier temps j'aurais
juste rapidement présenté en fait la
commune de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins c'est
une commune de 15000 bientôt 15000
habitants qui est situé donc au sud de
l'estuaires au nord de l'estuaire il y a
la ville de Saint-Nazaire qui s'élève
par sa construction navale et puis et
puis Airbus et puis Saint-Brevin fait
partie du pays grec qui est une une zone
située entre la Loire au nord et la
Vendée au sud dans ce pays de Ré en fait
il y a deux villes importantes Pornic
que vous connaissez peut-être et puis
donc Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
moi je j'ai été élu en 2008 pour la la
première fois donc j'habite
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins depuis 32 ans
puisque j'ai exerce la profession de
médecin généraliste dans cette dans
cette commune j'ai été élu la première
fois en 2008
où j'étais adjoint à la voirie au réseau
puis ensuite
en 2014 où je suis devenu adjoint au
bâtiment et performance énergétique et
en 2017 mon prédécesseur qui est
actuellement député il y a nicori a été
élu député et donc il m'avait demandé de
prendre la suite donc depuis 2017 je
suis maire de la commune et j'ai été élu
en 2020
en 2016
nous avons eu donc c'était mon
prédécesseur Yannick Cory suite au
démantèlement de la jungle de Calais en
fait nous avons vu arriver il nous a été
imposé par par l'État en fait l'arrivée
de migrants et la création d'un centre
d'accueil d'urgence en fait de
demandeurs d'asile et ce centre ce
centre d'accueil de demandeurs
étaient situés dans une dans un ancien
centre de vacances qui appartenait au
comité d'entreprise d'EDF-GDF et qui
n'était plus en fonction puisqu'il était
plus aux normes
donc depuis 2016 nous accueillons des
ces deux demandeurs d'asile et puis sans
la moindre difficulté alors en 2016
juste avant leur arrivée ça va être un
petit peu chaud quand même puisque il y
avait comme deux coups de feu qui avait
été tiré sur le bâtiment voilà il y
avait eu également une réunion publique
qui avait permis de s'affronter en fin
de compte les ceux qui étaient
favorables à l'arrivée de ces migrants
puis bien entendu j'irai les parties
d'extrême droite et qui s'y était opposé
mais le reste du temps ça s'était bien
passé et puis c'était créer également
une association pour les aider et puis
les différentes associations brévinoises
en fait ont participé
à l'inclusion de de ces demandeurs
d'asile
tout se passait très bien en
2018 donc j'étais devenu maire de
Saint-Brevin et là c'était le récupérer
en fin de compte certains migrants
certains demandeurs d'asile qui a été à
Nantes et notamment au niveau du square
David de Nantes et Johanna Roland la
mère de Nantes m'avait contacté en me
disant
qu'ils allaient être qu'ils allaient
venir sur notre sur notre centre
d'accueil et là même chose donc
parfaitement accueilli nos associations
qui se sont également occupées d'eux
pour leur apprendre le français pour
leur faire du sport enfin bon tout se
passait très bien dans dans la
population avec ces demandeurs d'asile
en le 11 mars 2021
j'avais invité le sous-préfet à
Saint-Brevin
à visiter un bunker puisque nous en
avons plein bien entendu sur notre sur
le littoral et dans notre commune qui a
été réhabilité et à la fin de cette
visite
il m'apprend que les États a décidé que
cette hébergement d'urgence en fait
c'est une date va devenir un cada et de
façon pérenne
il me l'a appris comme ça parce que j'ai
même pas reçu je dirais de courrier pour
mal annoncer ça a été vraiment de façon
verbale
le choix puisqu'en plus se bâtiment
était puisqu'il appartenait au CE2 EDF
était en vente donc il y avait déjà des
promoteurs qui étaient intéressés pour
pour ce centre
et donc le préfet me dit de toute façon
vous l'aurez donc essayer de trouver un
autre site
qui puisse accueillir ce cadavre
nous avions au sud au sud de la commune
des bâtiments qui étaient en friche qui
était une ancienne colonie en friche en
fait avec deux bâtiments et une petite
maison qui sont situés à côté d'une
école maternelle et primaire et puis à
côté d'une forêt la forêt de la pierre
et donc j'appelle j'avais gardé les
coordonnées de d'un représentant de
l'association Aurore qui gère les
cadavres au niveau national et je l'ai
appelé en lui parlant de ce site et en
lui posant c'est comme question voilà
c'est situé à côté d'une école
maternelle et primaire est-ce que ça
peut avoir des conséquences est-ce que
c'est un problème
il me répond bien sûr non il n'y a pas
de problème le fait que ce soit à côté
d'une école et puis
il me rappelle deux semaines après en me
disant qu'il descendait avec toute son
équipe de façon à pouvoir visiter le
site donc c'est ce qui s'est fait et
puis donc ils ont validé ce site de la
piratelé puisqu'il y avait un avantage
en fait il y avait deux bâtiments et une
maison et c'est ce qu'il me disait c'est
à dire que dans beaucoup de cadas
actuellement en France où il y a un seul
bâtiment il est difficile en fait
d'accueillir à la fois des voilà des
femmes et des enfants mélangées à des
hommes et donc là le fait d'avoir deux
bâtiments ça permettait de faire quelque
chose qui permettrait d'accueillir en
fait des familles c'est-à-dire des
femmes et des enfants
donc ça évolué
ils ont validé
ce site et puis les travaux
l'état également validé ce site et les
travaux pouvaient éventuellement
démarrer très rapidement donc en avril
la première difficulté
dans ce dans ce cas là qui était tout
simplement une délocalisation
dans un autre quartier
c'est que l'État et ses représentants ne
souhaitaient pas communiquer
il ne souhaite pas ne souhaitait pas
informer les habitants ils ont laissé la
municipalité et bien sans charger alors
que c'était pourtant un projet un projet
de l'État c'était donc cette première
difficulté on a donc organisé une
réunion avec les parents d'élèves avec
la directrice de l'école
avec les différentes associations on a
une association qui est également au
sein de l'école
qui gère les accueils de loisirs sans
hébergement
voilà on a réuni tout ce petit monde de
façon à les informer de ce projet et ça
a été fait ça le 5 octobre 2021 en
mairie
dès le lendemain parce qu'on savait très
bien que ça allait diffuser il y a toute
vitesse bien sûr
on avait préparé un flyer qu'on a boité
en fait dans tout le quartier
et également avec des messages qui ont
été publiés à la fois sur les réseaux et
sur le site de la commune nous avons à
Saint-Brevin une petite un petit journal
hebdomadaire qui est mis dans les
différents commerces dans les brésiles
moi peuvent avoir également sur le site
c'était également dans ce dans ce bref
info et puis également dans le magazine
municipal de Novembre Décembre 2021 et
puis bien entendu il y avait de nombreux
articles de la presse qui le relataient
de se passait bien mais pour la première
fois c'est la municipalité en fin de
compte qui a annoncé ça et qui a été
chargé de l'expliquer en fait à la
population
début d'année 2022
on fait des des groupes de travail et
notamment avec l'association
Aurore et également le constructeur cisn
qui était chargé en fait de faire les
les travaux pour réhabiliter ce site et
construire ce cadavre
et puis là on commence à percevoir il y
a quelque part en
quelque part en élèves et de riverains
qui contestait un petit peu ce site vu
que c'était à proximité de l'école et
qui ont créé un collectif un collectif
de la préservation de la pierre et ils
ont lancé une pétition ça faisait pas
énormément de bruit la pétition elle est
quasiment pas monté en nombre de
signatures
le permis de construire a été délivré
aux constructeurs cisn le 10 janvier
le 7 février 2022 lors de notre conseil
municipal on a validé la vente du
terrain
à l'unanimité donc à l'association
Aurore
et puis ce collectif de préservation de
la pirate les a déposer un recours
gracieux contre le permis le 9 mars 2022
que l'on a rejeté en fait le 22 mars ils
ne sont pas les plus loin le collectif
n'a pas déposé de recours auprès du
tribunal administratif
bien sûr il y avait des panneaux de
chantier qui ont été régulièrement
dégradés
et puis en septembre 2022
les travaux ont débuté
le 15 octobre 2022 une première
manifestation est organisée par ce
collectif de la pirater et réuni à peu
près une quarantaine de personnes dont
la majorité proviennent déjà de
l'extérieur de la commune puisque sur
Saint-Brévin il y a quand même
relativement peu de personnes qui sont à
l'extrême notamment à l'extrême droite
donc très peu de Brévinois et très
rapidement le se collectif s'est aperçu
que avec quelques personnes en fait il
allait pas pouvoir faire bouger
la mairie d'autant plus que je vous dis
ça avait été voté à l'unanimité en
conseil municipal et donc il a fait
appel directement à l'extrême droite et
à tous les groupusculte extrême droite
et le 11 décembre 2022 une nouvelle
manifestation est organisée là qui
réunit une centaine de personnes mais je
vous dis toujours très très peu de
Brévinois donc il se réunissent devant
la mairie et il y avait également une
contre manifestation qui a été pilotée
par l'association brévinoise qui s'était
écrit en 2016 justement pour aider les
demandeurs d'asile
donc ça a été voilà c'est bien géré par
géré par les forces de l'ordre qui ont
tout fait pour éviter qu'ils se
rencontrent qu'ils se voient
lors de mes vœux à la population j'ai
rappelé en fin de compte ce projet qui
n'était à l'origine pas bien entendu par
un projet de la municipalité mais voilà
puisque ça avait été l'avant du terrain
avait été voté à l'unanimité voilà en
disant que toute la municipalité bien
entendu soutenait ce projet de cada
et puis à partir de là
ça a commencé donc avec
différents articles sur les réseaux
sociaux
des menaces des intimidations
alors également beaucoup d'articles sur
un site qui s'appelle Riposte Laïque
voilà où on était mis en pâture en
permanence que ce soit moi la directrice
de l'école qui en plus est une nouvelle
directrice qui a débuté à la rentrée de
septembre
la présidente de l'association des
parents d'élèves voilà avec les photos
bien entendu mis sur ce site et puis je
vous dis pas voilà toutes les menaces en
dessous des différentes insultes
ça a continué donc bien entendu on a
alerté la gendarmerie on leur demandant
ce qu'il ce qu'il pouvait faire
et la réponse et vous allez vous la
répéter très souvent c'était toujours
liberté d'expression donc on ne peut
rien faire
et puis ces manifestations puisqu'il y
avait également un projet un peu
similaire à Calac c'était voilà qu'on a
réussi on a gagné donc à Saint-Brévin et
bien on va continuer et on va faire
monter monter la pression et j'ai reçu
moi deux semaines d'intervalle
un tract dans ma boîte aux lettres
personnelle ou bien montrer sa veille où
j'habitais de tracts ignoble puisque je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez c'était
en 2014 l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui
était dans une colonie à Saint-Brévin
qui avait été enlevé qui avait été
retrouvé tué dans une dans un dans une
mare à Guérande
ça n'avait strictement rien à voir avec
cette affaire avec avec des migrants
et dans ce trac j'avais la photo de de
ce petit garçon
en rappelant l'histoire et en dessous de
marquer Vlas qui risque de se passer à
sabrevin avec 110 migrants voilà la
semaine suivante la même chose
la photo du d'une petite fille alors
encore plus horrible parce qu'il mettait
la photo avant et ensuite après
j'imagine pas la deuxième photo est
toujours avec ce même discours quelque
chose qui on essaie de chercher c'était
même pas passé en France donc
voilà le type de tract que j'ai reçu
bien entendu on a transmis ça à la
gendarmerie toujours la même réponse
liberté d'expression
le
janvier je fais un courrier au préfet
voilà pour lui dire tout ce qui se
passait notamment toutes ces menaces
qu'il y avait moi j'avais eu également
une menace ce ne sera pas une tarte à la
crème une tarte aux plombs donc
je fais un courrier au préfet demandant
en fait un soutien de l'État parce que
c'est vrai qu'on se sentait un petit peu
au niveau de la commune de Saint-Brevin
démuni en fait on avait l'impression de
se retrouver de se retrouver seul
courrier revenu sans réponse
début 2023 également
[Musique]
on organise également à chaque fois en
début d'année et c'était en février
l'accueil des nouveaux brevinois et bien
entendu on a retrouvé quelques membres
du collectif qui était à la sortie et
qui harcelait les personnes qui
ressortaient avec également distribution
d'un tract haineux et pour les personnes
qui souhaitaient pas prendre leur tract
bien entendu ils étaient également
insultés ils ont distribué à plusieurs
reprises des tracts également sur le
marché de Saint-Brevin et puis le pire
ils ont distribué un jour des tracts
au niveau à l'entrée de l'école et nous
à Saint-Brévin on a une commune qui est
très plate une commune où il y a
beaucoup tout est fait pour faire du
vélo et on a donc beaucoup d'enfants qui
se rendent notamment en primaire à
l'école à vélo donc ils sont pas
forcément toujours accompagnés par leurs
parents et ce collectif distribuait ces
tracténiens bien entendu aux parents qui
accompagnent les enfants mais également
aux enfants qui venaient seuls en fait
les tracts étaient mis dans leur
cartable voilà nous l'avons signalé à la
gendarmerie qui était présente sur les
lieux mais qui les a qui ne les a pas
empêché de distribuer ce tract et de
continuer
beaucoup de parents d'élèves aussi
se sont sentis menacés puisque par
l'association de parents d'élèves ils
avaient récupéré en fait les différents
mails des parents d'élèves et puis
pareil harceler les parents d'élèves qui
ne voulaient pas venus qui les suivaient
pas
et les harcelets également par par les
sur les boîtes mails
le
[Musique]
donc on a organisé le 27 janvier
une réunion avec justement les parents
d'élèves pour essayer un petit peu de
rassurer de rassurer tout le monde et
nous avons nous avions convoqué à cette
réunion un lieu de temps de gendarmerie
pour que les personnes se sentent
rassurées puis qu'ils puissent poser
toutes les questions à la gendarmerie et
là la réponse était toujours la même
toute façon ça ne sert à rien de déposer
plainte nous ne ferons rien voilà c'est
la liberté d'expression le tract liberté
d'expression peut rien faire contre son
tract
le 7 février 203
le conseil municipal a été envahi par
les membres de ce collectif il y avait
encore une fois très peu de Brévinois
mais surtout des personnes extérieures à
Saint-Brevin et nous avions prévu en fin
de compte
de faire voter une motion justement pour
donner un petit peu les condamner les
différentes menaces qu'il y avait sur
les différentes personnes que ce soit
les élus également les membres des
parents d'élèves et la directrice de
l'école cette motion était bien entendu
votée à l'unanimité et toutes ces
personnes en fait ben voilà ont assisté
à ce conseil municipal on avait prévu
quand même la gendarmerie prévenu la
gendarmerie au cas où vous ferez chaud
de façon à pouvoir les évacuer mais je
pense qu'ils attendaient une chose que
je demande le huis clos donc
comme ils l'ont fait aucun bruit en fait
ils sont restés ils ont résisté à tout
le conseil municipal j'ai pas pu les
évacuer puisque ils l'ont fait aucun
bruit
une autre réunion a été organisée trois
jours après le 10 février avec le
commandant de gendarmerie qui regroupe
en fait tout le pays de rêve donc
notamment les gendarmerie importante de
Saint-Brevin et de et de Pornic et
Monsieur le sous-préfet que nous avions
convié
à cette réunion j'étais avec ma première
adjointe qui est aussi avait pris pas
mal de coups sur Riposte Laïque et puis
mon adjointe aux affaires scolaires
puisque bien entendu elle entend on
s'occupant des écoles bien entendu elle
avait été confrontée
[Musique]
à ce collectif
et lors de cette réunion donc on a
rappelé aussi vous préfet tout ce qui
s'était passé voilà
je peux vous assurer qu'on a été quand
même très très surpris
le sous-préfet nous a tout simplement
dit mais les menaces mais vous savez moi
j'en ai tous les jours des menaces
le commandant de gendarmerie
c'est pas grand chose ce sont simplement
des des menaces voilà c'est de
l'intimidation ça ne sert à rien de
déposer plainte toute façon on ne fera
rien c'est la liberté d'expression voilà
on a toujours eu ce lait de motif de
liberté d'expression aussi bien utilisé
par la gendarmerie que par le
sous-préfet
donc quand ils sont repartis de cette
réunion on s'est retrouvé tous les trois
avec mes deux adjointe et je voudrais
qu'on était un peu dépité un peu choqué
en fin de compte de ce qu'on avait
entendu et là on s'est aperçu qu'on se
retrouveait totalement démuni seul
abandonné par les services de l'État et
qu'on allait de voir et bien continuer à
affronter en fin de compte cette montée
en puissance là de ce
collectifs qui ont fin de compte ne
représentaient même plus un Brevin mais
qui était le collectif qui faisait venir
toute la l'extrême droite et tous les
groupuscules d'extrême droite
le suite à cette réunion le 15 février
j'ai fait un courrier au procureur de la
République pour dénoncer en fin de
compte tous ces faits
toute une liste on a repris toutes les
menaces toutes les insultes tout ce qui
s'était passé voilà en rappelant
également le
manque de soutien de l'État
et nous avons reçu aucun courrier de
retour de la procureur
voilà
aucune réponse
le 25 février 2023
c'est pour ça que c'est important toute
cette chronologie non c'est peut-être un
peu long mais ça vous permet de voir un
peu comment
ça s'est passé
le 25 avril 2023 dans l'après-midi a été
organisé pareil par le même collectif
donc une manifestation donc c'était une
manipulation qui le déclarait mais on
s'apercevait que ceux qui déclarait la
manifestation très souvent il y avait un
Brévinois et puis les deux autres
personnes étaient en dehors de
Saint-Brévin
donc 250 personnes
sont venues
ont bloqué la ville les commerces ont
créé également des
des dégâts puisque bien entendu qui dit
manifestation d'extrême droite vous avez
en face l'ultra gauche également qui
appelle à venir tout simplement pour se
taper dessus
c'est vrai que ce sont des ce genre de
choses qu'on n'avait jamais vu à
Saint-Brévin qu'on n'avait jamais connu
nous
à Saint-Brevin
voilà il y avait eu le matin d'organiser
par le
les associations qui soutiennent le
projet une contre manifestation qui
avait réussi pratiquement réussi à
réunir 1300 personnes voilà ça c'était
ils avaient organisé ça le matin
justement pour pas être en confrontation
avec les agressions de l'extrême droite
et de l'ultra gauche
le 18 mars
lors d'une cérémonie publique de la
commémoration de la catastrophe du
poivre on a il y a une catastrophe
puisque Saint-Brevin fait partie de la
poche sud de Saint-Nazaire et il y avait
eu une catastrophe à l'époque en 1945 ou
une vingtaine en fin de compte de
personnes
sont décédées dans une explosion et donc
il y a un monument
chaque année bien entendu on fait cette
commémoration de cette catastrophe du
bois avant je me suis retrouvé donc à
chaque fois bien entendu lors de toutes
ces cérémonies patriotiques
les gendarmes sont prévenus
et ce 18 mars en fait après la cérémonie
bien entendu le verre de l'amitié dans
une salle qui était fait justement
puisque c'est pas très loin de cette
école de la pire attelée dans une des
salles de l'école
et je me suis retrouvé en fait je les ai
vu arriver
entouré par ce collectif à peu près 6 7
membres
qui m'ont vraiment entouré donc je
pouvais même pas voilà partir il y a eu
des des échanges et à la fin de durant
l'entretien ils m'ont demandé
d'essayer de les aider pour obtenir un
rendez-vous avec le préfet voilà donc je
me suis engagé à essayer de faire
obtenir ce rendez-vous avec le préfet
et plusieurs repris certains m'ont dit
mais vous dormez bien voilà j'en avais
pas pris quand je précise c'est l'été le
18 mars et on va vous raccompagner
jusqu'à votre véhicule
c'était le 18 mars le 22 mars donc dans
la nuit entre 4h30 et 5h du matin donc
j'étais victime d'un attentat criminel
voilà
vous mais
probablement un engin explosif a été
lancé mis entre mes deux véhicules
bien entendu ont pris feu et ça c'est
propagé en fait également à mon domicile
et nous étions bien sûr dans la maison
heureusement nous avons été
réveillé par par les bruits et puis
également par trois personnes qui
revenaient de leur travail chez Airbus à
Saint-Nazaire qui ont vu les flammes qui
ont appelé les pompiers et qui ont
insisté
de façon à nous faire sortir de la
maison puisque donc tout était en train
de brûler
le jour de l'incendie ce mercredi 22
mars j'ai eu bien entendu
plusieurs coups de fil
de la procureur
voilà qui m'a appelé pour m'apporter son
soutien elle avait toujours pas répondu
au courrier précédent
j'ai eu un coup de fil de Monsieur le
sous-préfet
qui est également m'apporter son soutien
et puis un coup de téléphone également
de Monsieur le Préfet
des Pays de la Loire monsieur rigolo
rose qui était là depuis assez peu de
temps
qui est venu également qui m'a appelé
pour m'apporter son soutien
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard le vendredi en fin
de compte j'ai essayé avec la presse de
lors d'une interview de dire un petit
peu justement ce manque de soutien
d'État seulement j'ai été coupé par la
presse donc ça n'a pas ça n'a pas été
diffusé voilà et donc de colère j'ai
fait un courrier avérant parce que oui
j'oublie Olivier Véran m'avait également
appelé le jour même c'est le seul
ministre d'ailleurs qui qui m'est appelé
ce jour-là
et donc de jour après sous le coup de la
colère donc j'ai décidé d'écrire à
Olivier Véran
en envoyant un double de mon courrier
bien entendu
à Monsieur Darmanin
au préfet sous préfet également au
président de la République
deux jours également après après
l'incendie monsieur le sous-préfet est
allé couper un ruban à Pornic donc pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas le coin
pour aller à Pornic quand on vient de
Saint-Nazaire on traverse la Loire par
le pont donc on traverse obligatoirement
ma commune de Saint-Brévin
la moindre des choses quand même un peu
d'humanité il aurait été bon quand même
qu'il puisse s'arrêter dans la commune
pour me demander en fait mes nouvelles
en fait puisqu'il traversait ma commune
et bien non ne s'est même pas même pas
arrêté l'état découper son ruban à
Pornic
le
[Musique]
j'ai reçu alors un courrier également
donc un courrier d'olive Véran qui
répondait pas aux questions que je lui
transmettais dans dans le courrier et
j'ai reçu également un courrier du
président de la République Monsieur
Macron qui m'assurait de leur soutien
mais bien entendu qui répondait pas
voilà aux questions de mon courrier
justement sur le fait qu'il y avait eu
aucun soutien de l'État
le 4 avril 2023
j'étais également additionné par la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
nationale
notamment concernant la loi sur
l'immigration et
en fait c'est cette audition avait été
prévue avant l'incendie et je me suis
retrouvé
donc c'était en visio avec le maire de
bellabre qui lui aussi
à qui on a imposé un cada
mais lui qui a la chance en fait d'avoir
un soutien du sous-préfet et du préfet
puisque justement on a pu discuter
ensemble et donc il était surpris que
moi bien entendu je n'avais vraiment
aucune aucune relation avec le préfet
sous préfet alors que lui il les avait
pratiquement tous les jours au téléphone
ensuite
[Musique]
et on a reçu comme quoi en fait ça va
parfaitement le début avril également
une lettre
d'un maire
de le maire de Fameck
et en fin de compte c'était une lettre
d'insultes donc vous imaginez que j'ai
trouvé ça un peu un peu curieux en fin
de compte venant d'un collègue mère donc
nous ne l'avons appelé et en fait
c'était tout simplement une usurpation
d'identité il y a quelqu'un de sa
commune qui a pris du papier en tête
voilà recopier sa signature avec le
cachet de la commune une enveloppe de la
commune et cela mettait adressée donc
voilà et donc depuis bien entendu on lui
a fait remonter tout ça il a déposé
plainte aussitôt
le 7 avril j'ai écrit ou c'est préfets
pour lui demander en fait une protection
renforcée puisque sur les réseaux
sociaux commençaient à circuler
une nouvelle manifestation qui était
prévue pour le 29 avril
et donc vu ce qui s'était passé j'avais
pas envie à nouveau voilà de subir des
des violences
le sous-préfet m'a répondu le 13 avril
en m'indiquant
qu'ils allaient faire une évaluation des
des risques sur ma personne voilà parce
que j'ai eu comme réponse
et puis pas de nouvelles donc il a fallu
que je relance en fait par mail le 25
avril
et le sous-préfet le 28 avril en fait
m'a répondu donc la veille de cette
manifestation voilà que l'évaluation des
risques étaient toujours en cours et
elle est toujours actuellement
le
7 avril voilà
j'ai été invité par notre ami Joël
guerriot donc au Pouliguen qui
organisait en réunion sur les violences
auprès des élus justement pour expliquer
la situation
et puis
recréer une nouvelle fois pour du
sous-préfet en fin de compte qui était
présent à cette réunion le manque de
soutien il y avait également de
collègues maires qui étaient présentes
dont ma collègue de vues qui est une
commune à proximité de Saint-Brévin dont
le jugement a eu lieu c'est en début de
semaine voilà dont son prédécesseur
qu'il a harcelé en permanence en fait a
été a été condamné
et puis donc pour cette
manifestation du 29 avril nous étions
aperçus nous sur les réseaux sociaux
qui étaient appelés à manifester en fait
parce que nous avons vu à Paris ces
derniers jours c'est-à-dire toute une
formation
néonazi là de Rennes où il y avait plus
de 100 personnes qui devaient venir
justement sur Saint-Brevin
on avait également l'annonce bien
entendu de toute l'ultra gauche du
pedray de la région nantaise qui
appelait également un manifester tout
simplement pour venir se taper dessus
c'est clair donc j'ai le 17 avril j'ai
fait un courrier au préfet
en lui précisant justement tout ce que
nous avions trouvé et pour lui dire que
ça allait entraîner bien entendu des
troubles à l'ordre public et en lui
demandant d'interdire cette
manifestation
pas de réponse donc
le 25 avril nous avons également relancé
et la veille de la manifestation le
sous-préfet m'a envoyé un mail en disant
qu'il ne pouvait pas interdire cette
manifestation pour des raisons
juridiques ça c'était le matin et
l'après-midi nous on découvrait que le
préfet de Paris en fait
interdisait la manifestation autour du
stade de France donc de poids de mesure
même s'il y avait un recours mais bon le
nôtre ne pouvait pas l'interdire
juridiquement
quelques jours après la manifestation
bien sûr j'ai refait un courrier au
préfet en lui disant ce qui s'était
passé c'était voilà on l'avait averti
c'était quand même le week-end de trois
jours du 1er mai on a eu bien entendu
des dégradations au niveau de la ville
de Saint-Brévin au niveau de commerce
c'était un grand week-end on est quand
même une station balnéaire on a beaucoup
de monde qui vient et ce qui est obligé
en fin de compte un grand nombre de nos
commerces de centre-ville et bien fermé
pratiquement toute la journée
les dégradations également fait peur à
beaucoup de Brévinois parce que quand
vous voyez dans une petite commune qui
normalement est tranquille voilà arrivés
sans jeûne cagoulé tout de noir vêtus
dans le centre-ville vous rebrousser
chemin c'est vrai que
il y a eu une voiture qui a brûlé des
poubelles qui ont brûlées enfin pas mal
de dégâts donc dans ce courrier je
demandais également au préfet on lui a
annonçait qu'on allait faire
un détail de toutes ces dégradations et
qu'on allait lui envoyer la facture bien
entendu on sait très bien que il
participeront pas mais c'était voilà
purement purement symbolique qu'on
allait également faire chiffrer par nos
commerçants qui ont été obligés de
fermer en fait le manque à gagner
bien entendu aucune réponse à ce
courrier à ce jour
il n'y a même pas eu d'arrestation que
ce soit d'un côté ou de l'autre que ce
soit de l'ultra droit ou de l'ultra
gauche rien c'est-à-dire c'est c'est
manifestants et bien sont repartis
tranquillement chez eux après avoir
cassé j'ai eu le rapport de la
gendarmerie il y a quand même eu 98
grenades lacrymogène qui ont été lancés
dans une petite ville comme la mienne
donc
qui paraît phénoménal
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà
[Musique]
j'ai écrit donc le 30 avril également
préfet donc justement pour lui dire ça
son absence de soutien et puis justement
lui demandant les remboursements de de
tous ces dégâts
ensuite voyons cela et puis après longue
discussion avec ma famille vous imaginez
que voilà c'est très difficile de
continuer à vivre cela juste pour dire
il y a deux semaines lors du du week-end
du 8 mai mon fils qui habite Paris
est venu passer trois jours nous étions
à la terrasse d'un café le dimanche midi
donc en public et un une personne de se
collectif qui a dit bien entendu on est
des idées d'extrême droite se diriger
vers moi je l'avais vu arriver mais bien
entendu j'avais tourné la tête pour
justement ne pas le fixer du regard
il est venu directement vers nous en
m'insultant mais t'as pas fini de
le bazar à Saint-Brevin avait été
migrants enfin bon puis il a continué et
puis tout en continuant en essayant de
faire croire à tout le monde que c'était
moi-même qui avait mis l'incendie donc à
mes deux véhicules et à ma maison voilà
il a fini par par partir et donc j'ai
relaté ça la presse pour expliquer
pourquoi justement on ne voulait plus
vivre ça et puis ma femme pas non plus
rencontrer ce genre de personne et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
décidé de démissionner de ma fonction de
d'élus et de quitter et bien entendu
cette ville voilà qui m'avait accueilli
il y a il y a 32 ans
j'ai envoyé ma démission au préfet
le mardi qui a suivi et en fait il m'a
appelé le lendemain
voilà discuter je lui ai dit que j'avais
pas senti le soutien de l'État ça répond
ça a été mais si on vous a soutenu
lorsqu'il y a eu les manifestations
j'ai tout fait j'ai mis en fin de compte
trois compagnies de CRS pour éviter les
dégâts j'ai envoyé également un
sous-préfet d'astre la procureur qui
était présente sur site donc j'ai agi
voilà ça a été ça ça a été sa réponse
voilà faut savoir que le le préfet quand
il a écrit dans la presse qu'il m'a vu
régulièrement au téléphone
le jour où j'étais ma démission c'est la
deuxième fois je l'avais au téléphone je
l'ai eu la première fois le journal
l'incendie la seconde fois
lorsque je vais je vais donner ma
démission quant à Monsieur le sous-pré
fet je lis au téléphone comme je vous
l'ai dit le jour de l'incendie depuis
plus jamais
donc voilà un petit peu toute cette
chronologie sur tout ce qui est arrivé
c'est pour ça que quand j'ai parlé du
manque de soutien de l'État c'était
flagrant et surtout quand je vois dans
tous les messages soutiens que j'ai reçu
où il y a quand même voilà des cadavres
maintenant qui s'implante un peu partout
je m'aperçois que mes collègues mer
voilà on des relations importantes avec
les préfets sous préfet qui viennent
faire des réunions publiques pour
expliquer ce que c'est tout simplement
un cadavre la population alors que nous
nous n'avons pas eu ce genre de choses
et puis ce qui est désolant également
quand vous avez dû voir la communication
du préfet après après
ma démission parce que je m'attendais
pas à ce que ça fasse des remous des
remous comme ça c'est cette démission
quand il dit qu'il a organisé des
réunions publiques
je parle de la part d'un préfet mentir
et frontalement en public c'est quand
même important je sais pas il représente
l'État
il sait très bien qu'il a pas organisé
de réunions publiques on a toutes les
preuves il suffit de lui demander la
date il pourra pas en fournir il en a
pas fait
donc voilà un petit peu résumé
chronologiquement toute mon histoire
à Saint-Brevin
alors ce qui est amusant parce que je
pense que il y a dû y avoir des
retombées
certains ont dû se faire un peu taper
sur les doigts
sur l'histoire je vous ai raconté avec
ma famille il y a deux semaines puisque
j'ai raconté ça à la presse pour
expliquer pourquoi je souhaitais quitter
la commune
la gendarmerie m'a appelé en disant mais
vous n'avez pas déposé plainte
et donc j'ai déposé plainte voilà
ces jours-ci ils ont même entendu ma
femme qui était présente bien entendu
hier également qui a déposé plainte et
je me suis aperçu en allant signé ma
plainte hier en gendarmerie
et bien qu'ils étaient en train de
travailler
sur les tracts haineux
d'un seul coup on peut faire quelque
chose
sur le directeur de publication du site
Riposte Laïque parce que quand on leur
avait dit on nous dit mais non on peut
rien faire c'est un site on peut rien
faire on peut rien faire et là on a
appris que ils étaient en train de
monter tout un dossier pour pouvoir le
transmettre au Procureur
sur différentes choses également
notamment sur les tracts
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure que
j'ai reçu c'est pareil ils sont en train
de monter tout un dossier
tu es curieux des mois après voilà il a
fallu que tu arrives quelque chose pour
et puis que ça remonte d'un seul coup
voilà on prenne conscience que rien
n'avait été fait et puis que la liberté
d'expression va quand même ses limites
et maintenant donc ça bouge mais je
pense un peu trop tard
merci de
ce témoignage
[Applaudissements]
vous imaginez bien que j'ai plusieurs
demandes de parole mais Matthieu
d'Arnaud notre rapporteur de la mission
quelques questions puis le président
rappin le ministre bas monsieur le
équervé le ministre canner Monsieur
borgy et Madame Gatel
et Madame ku Kerman après
on va faire la liste on continue donc
monsieur darder merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Maire à mon tour
vous apporter à la fois mon soutien
personnel notre notre soutien et vous
remercier de ce propos que l'on imagine
à la fois poignant et parfois des
arsenans quand on sait et pour
s'intéresser entre autres sujets de qui
est au cœur de notre mission sur
l'avenir de la commune du maire à ce
sujet qui va grandissant de
confrontation des élus avec une violence
du du quotidien en essayant aussi de
voir comment on peut juguler comment on
peut apporter des réponses concrètes on
imagine aisément ce que vous avez été
amené à vivre et à revivre même puisque
vous avez rappelé ici même que
nombreux sont les faits qui vous ont
confrontés justement
assez à celles et ceux qui ont
été à l'origine
des de l'ensemble des violences
auxquelles vous avez été confronté moi
j'ai trois questions assez
succinctes et à la fois pratique la
première vous avez fait état de
l'ensemble
des fois où vous avez été amené à saisir
les autorités de l'État qu'il s'agisse
du préfet du sous-préfet on a bien
entendu que ce n'est que dernièrement
que la gendarmerie vous avez invité à
déposer plainte est-ce qu'auparavant il
vous aviez
déposé une main courante ou j'allais
dire été amené vous vous même ou
d'autres personnes puisqu'on imagine
aussi que l'ensemble des élus
municipales
municipaux pardon était amenés à vivre
ces épisodes à vos côtés à le faire
eux-mêmes ça c'est la première question
vous avez aussi fait état d'une
confrontation directe à l'issue
de l'accueil des nouveaux habitants de
votre commune avec
quelques personnes qui faisaient partie
des personnes qui se sont opposées et
qui vous ont j'allais dire à plusieurs
reprises vivement interpellées est-ce
qu'elle a à la suite de cet épisode il y
a eu un contact avec le préfet et pour
être très clair est-ce que l'État a
cherché à rentrer directement
en contact avec avec l'ensemble de ces
de ces personnes notamment pour
expliquer les raisons de ces décisions
s'agissant du CADA et puis le troisième
point parce qu'on imagine aisément la
douleur de ce que vous avez pu vivre
feta notamment du soutien psychologique
est-ce qu'à un moment donné au-delà des
témoignages de sympathie j'imagine et de
soutien est-ce que vous avez manifesté
une demande de soutien
psychologique est-ce que vous vous avez
vous-même eu besoin parce que on sait la
violence et surtout parfois le sentiment
de solitude auquel on est confronté
quand on vit cela parce que on peut
l'exprimer on peut en parler mais il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'il y a une
forme de solitude face à la violence de
ses actes donc est-ce que vous avez
engagé une démarche par rapport par
rapport à cela en tout cas merci de vos
réponses et merci de ce précieux
témoigner je signale pour la bonne
organisation de nos débats que si le
rapporteur un peu plus de temps les
autres ont deux minutes voilà la
question monsieur Rabat
merci merci
madame monsieur les présidents
rapporteur Monsieur le Maire d'abord
bravo pour votre façon d'exprimer les
choses je dirais presque sans émotion et
pourtant on sent très bien que au fond
de vous il y a une émotion très forte
celle de quelqu'un qui a été bafoué
qui exerce une profession noble dans sa
commune qui n'est qui est rare
aujourd'hui dans certaines communes mais
qui exerce une profession noble et ma
première question en tant que confrère
c'est quel était le ressenti de votre
patientèle si vous travaillez encore sur
cette question et comment comment
l'a-t-elle ressenti la deuxième et je ne
sais pas si je pourrais avoir les
réponses parce que je préside ma
commission dans quelques dans quelques
minutes
c'est
il y a eu aussi de la part des
parlementaires et je ne sais pas à quel
niveau mais en tout cas moi je me
souviens très bien d'une question de
Laurence Garnier en séance en séance
publique
interpellant les ministres sur sur ce
problème particulier sur votre problème
particulier je voulais savoir s'il y
avait eu des retours de cela et vous
n'avez pas non plus évoqué votre député
je suppose qu'il est intervenu aussi sur
le sujet étant député de la majorité on
peut s'étonner qu'il n'y ait pas eu un
soutien plus fort sur sur votre
situation qui qui au somme de tout ce
que vous nous avez exposé était une
situation très très inquiétante en tout
cas moi je constate une chose c'est
qu'on a affaire au tonneau des Danaïdes
à tous les niveaux
sécurité
probité justice mais finalement vous
n'avez eu aucune réponse et on a vu le
château de cartes s'écroulait par
l'événement final qui a été celui de
votre démission en tout cas Monsieur le
Maire tout mon soutien bravo et bravo
aussi au confrères parce que je suppose
que ça devait être difficile d'assumer
toutes ces fonctions en même temps merci
Monsieur ben n'aura pas monsieur le
ministre bar ce questeur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Maire je dois vous dire que je suis
profondément indigné
par toutes les défaillances voir les
dysfonctionnements que la chronologie
que vous avez
méthodiquement
exposé révèle et je suis d'autant plus
indigné que voici maintenant près de 5
ans
à la suite de la mort brutale du maire
de signe Monsieur Michel dans le Var
nous avons procédé à une enquête auprès
des maires de France qui a révélé
l'ampleur du phénomène à la suite de
laquelle nous avons fait des
propositions dont certaines il est vrai
on était reprises à notre initiative
dans la loi mais qui comportait aussi
des mesures d'organisation très
importante
et notre démocratie municipale elle
repose sur le fait que tout citoyen peut
devenir mère mais un maire ne fait pas
l'école des mers il n'a pas la formation
d'un magistrat ou d'un sous-préfet et
par conséquent nous avions demandé
instamment à ce que à chaque fois que
l'on repérait des menaces des insultes
des agressions comme celles que vous
avez
rappelé
immédiatement se mettre en place une
cellule de crise
pilotée par le préfet et qui prennent
elle-même l'initiative de demander qu'il
y ait des poursuites pénales quand des
propos haineux des menaces des insultes
étaient proférées de sorte que le maire
ne soit pas tout seul
nous avons eu à la suite de cette
demande des instructions données au
préfet à l'époque et des instructions
données au procureur de la République
par le garde des sceaux je constate en
vous écoutant que nous en sommes restés
en tout cas pour votre cas dans cette
étape cette fixation terrible que vous
avez décrit
à la situation antérieure ça n'est pas à
vous je pense mais vous réagirez
peut-être à mon propos de prendre les
initiatives vous devez être guidés et
accompagné et dès le début pour ne pas
laisser les choses se dégrader comme
elles l'ont été et c'est d'autant plus
choquant qu'en plus il s'agissait d'une
affaire dans laquelle l'État était
concerné au premier chef puisque la
création d'un centre d'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile n'est pas une
initiative municipale donc tout ceci est
scandaleux de bout en bout je tenais à
le dire même si c'est pas formulé sous
forme de question mais vous pourrez bien
sûr réagir et je suis comme
Jean-François Rapin je ne peux pas
rester malheureusement mais je voulais
dire ça
bien mais merci Monsieur entre les mains
les deux courriers de réponse que nous
avions eu et du garde des sceaux et du
mis sur l'intérieur en date du 7 avril
2021 et du 6 mai 2021 au terme desquels
des engagements ont été pris
qui manifestement à ce stade n'ont pas
été tenu bien monsieur Loïc Hervé
oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Maire bon comme l'ensemble
de mes collègues on est assez stupéfait
parce qu'il vous est arrivé moi il m'est
arrivé des choses à peu près similaires
il y a une dizaine d'années mais j'avais
pu bénéficier d'un soutien
incomparablement plus important de la
part du préfet
et des gendarmes pour faire face à une
situation qui est aussi mettait en cause
ou en danger ma famille
je reviens sur le début de votre
intervention et sur le rôle du maire
dans les questions d'accueil des
cadavres parce que c'était dans mon cas
exactement le même problème est-ce que
vous pensez que
au-delà de l'absence de soutien à très
court terme dont vous n'avez pas
bénéficié que que tout démart d'ici
c'est-à-dire que le maire d'une ville
aussi importante que la vôtre c'est une
ville de 15000 habitants ne soit pas
associée
en termes de gouvernance à toutes les
décisions
principales qui qui touche à à cette
question de l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile sur un territoire est-ce que
c'est pas ça qui fait que finalement
vous êtes à chaque à chaque fois dans
dans un une situation de jouer le
mauvais rôle et et
pour nous législateur je pense que ça ça
et c'est vrai pour cette politique
publique là c'est vrai malheureusement
pour
pour bien d'autres donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'important je
pense que on peut voter toutes les lois
du monde elle repose sur des êtres
humains
qui sont en charge de les appliquer et
qu'il faudrait quand même une un
bouleversement intellectuel de
l'administration des concentrés de
l'État pour comprendre ce qui est en
train de se passer dans notre pays et
vous apporter son soutien dernière
question plus triviale est-ce que votre
décision est irréversible
bien merci Monsieur Hervé monsieur Miss
Patrick Kanner monsieur le Président oui
monsieur le Président Monsieur le Maire
vous êtes devenu un symbole je crois que
symbole défendu par tous les maires de
France avait un juste titre puisque
quelque part sur vous la foudre est
tombée alors que beaucoup de mers
essayent de l'éviter dans leur vie
quotidienne
vous êtes représentant de vos
concitoyens
encore aujourd'hui mais vous êtes aussi
représentent de l'état d'être un agent
de l'État comme mère et ma question
porte sur l'actualité de ce matin moi
j'étais très choquée mais je crois que
je suis pas le seul d'avoir lu dans la
presse que le préfet
devait s'opposer à votre démission
dans l'attente du rendez-vous que vous
allez avoir ce soir avec madame la
Première ministre
je ne sais pas si ma première histoire
des arguments qui vous ferait revenir
sur votre décision d'ailleurs je ne
demande pas de me répondre quoique si
vous voulez la presse sera intéressée
elle nous regarde à l'étage mais en fait
c'est cette relation de confiance qui
est en train d'être rompu entre les îles
locaux et l'exécutif et pas uniquement
sur la faire très douloureuse qui vous
concerne mais sur bien d'autres bien
d'autres sujets donc ma question est
simple c'est aujourd'hui avec le recul
qui est le vôtre
quel message peut-on faire passer à
l'exécutif nous sommes représentants de
la nation nous sommes en faisant des
collectivités locales tout à l'heure
j'aurais l'occasion d'interpeller madame
le Premier ministre sur votre situation
je tiens à le dire et je compte bien lui
demander
bien évidemment si elle a pris
conscience de la situation dans laquelle
se trouve énormément d'élus locaux moi
dans mon département du Nord le nombre
de maires qui me disent on en a
ras-le-bol on en a ras-le-bol et
seulement terrifiant ça se traduit pas
automatiquement par une démission c'est
se traduit par une lassitude qui est
extrêmement dangereuse pour le
fonctionnement de la démocratie merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur Seigneur
Monsieur le Maire cher collègue je
voulais exprimer 3 sentiments et vous
poser une question le premier sentiment
c'est vous remercier vous remercier
d'être présent ici pour témoigner malgré
l'épreuve que vous et votre famille
traversée le deuxième sentiment c'est
celui du soutien unanime que nous vous
avons apporté que nous vous apportons
parce que nous avons été révulsés par
les violences que vous avez subies que
votre famille a subi je me fais le
porte-parole de l'Association des maires
de l'Hérault parce que depuis maintenant
15 jours il ne me parle que de vous et
de ce qui vous est arrivé et je voulais
vous apporter le soutien des maires de
l'Hérault je voulais enfin vous dire que
nous sommes indignés par l'inaction de
l'État à travers le témoignage qui a été
le vôtre très factuel c'est finalement
une succession d'abandon dont vous avez
été victime c'est une somme de l'acheter
dont vous avez été victime madame la
Première ministre va vous recevoir
aujourd'hui
elle voudra certainement vous demander
de revenir sur votre démission
je lui suggéré au préalable de faire
deux annonces la première c'est de vous
présenter des excuses des excuses pour
l'abandon dans l'état fait preuve dans
cette affaire la seconde chose que je
lui suggérer de faire c'est de limoger
les hauts fonctionnaires qui sont censés
représenter l'état dans votre
département parce que la somme de ces
défaillances frisent l'incompétence on
ne peut pas laisser un département on ne
peut pas laisser des élus et des
habitants livrés à de tel aux
fonctionnaires dans votre département ma
question est la suivante dans l'effet
que vous avez subi est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire la nature du soutien
dont vous avez bénéficié de la part
d'élus qu'il soit nationaux ou locaux
depuis l'annonce de la création du CADA
jusqu'à l'annonce de votre démission
merci monsieur borgy madame la
Présidente Gatel
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci pour cette audition je crois que
je n'ai pas de question Monsieur le
Maire mais il n'empêche que je prenne
mon temps de parole monsieur
je voulais vous dire avec beaucoup de
respect
ce qui est sincèrement mon admiration ce
matin pour la manière dont vous vous
adressez à nous
avec
beaucoup de sincérité un sens des
responsabilités
qui nous impressionne tous et la manière
dont vous décrivez parfois même avec un
peu d'humour ce qui est juste une
tragédie de dérapage
incontrôler qui conduisent
à pour vous qui vous êtes engagé pour
servir votre ville un moment à devoir la
quitter avec votre famille et donc
Monsieur le Maire ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est vous êtes où aujourd'hui
nous vivons la conséquence
d'une faillite d'une chaîne de
responsabilité d'une faillite de ce que
j'appelle l'abandon de l'État à côté des
mains ou un état des je veux vous
exécutez vous vous débrouillez et on
voit aujourd'hui où cela nous conduit
dans une société extrêmement violente et
je pense que Monsieur le Maire nous vous
devons et c'est le propos que le
gouvernement devra tenir nous vous
devrons d'être aujourd'hui la cause de
notre survie républicaine et de la prise
de conscience que partout en toutes
circonstances et sur tous les
territoires l'État doit être là à vos
côtés parce que vous êtes la valeur
absolue de la République vous l'incarnez
la preuve vous êtes aujourd'hui
transformé en bouc émissaire d'une
violence et d'un abandon de l'État merci
Monsieur le Maire merci
à monsieur le Président peut-être à mon
tour et effectivement combien de le
faire notre collègue Françoise Gattel je
crois tout d'abord
apporter notre soutien mais vous dire
aussi ma stupéfaction à l'écoute de
votre témoignage
et cela ne changera rien de tout ce qui
vous est arrivé de ce que vous avez subi
mais tout de même et heureusement que
dans d'autres départements les choses ne
se passent pas ainsi parce que si nous
en sommes maintenant à plus d'un millier
de mer qui ont démissionné depuis le
début du mandat il y en aurait bien plus
et donc effectivement dans le témoignage
qui qui est le vôtre
[Musique]
on prend conscience j'ai envie de dire
faire après fait d'une défaillance en
cascade
qui interpelle très très fortement parce
que
infini les choses pour votre vie pour
celle de votre famille ne se finissent
pas dramatiquement mais tout est
possible et tout est inimaginait et tout
est imaginable j'ai juste une question
et sans polémiquer est-ce que il y a il
n'y a pas eu finalement une
sous-estimation
des menaces à votre égard convaincu
peut-être un peu rapidement de la part
de certains que ce n'était que quelques
individus excités et menaçants alors
qu'il y avait bien dans votre cas
une organisation
vous les avez cités et une volonté
compris de l'extrême droite très
déstabilisante à votre égard et je n'en
reste qu'à ce cas là bien évidemment je
ne crois que chaque cas est unique même
si malheureusement et d'autres collègues
l'ont dit précédemment il se multiplient
et ils sont de plus en plus nombreux et
doivent nous interpeller parce que quand
il n'y aura plus de mer c'est tout
simplement la démocratie et la
République qui sera mise à terre
mal monsieur Jean-Michel Arnaud
oui monsieur président rapidement
puisque leur avance d'abord vous dire
comme cela a été dit par d'autres
collègues Monsieur le Maire en tant que
président la session des maires de mon
département les Hautes-Alpes et
sénateurs
je crains que la situation vous décrivez
soit une situation hélas qui ne soit pas
totalement isolée nous avons
régulièrement des témoignages de nature
différente qui peuvent privés qui
peuvent être politique liées à des
projets spécifiques ou simplement une
ambiance générale dans ce pays qui est
de taper sur toutes celles et ceux qui
ont une autorité
ou leur famille
et permettez-moi de le dire j'ai aussi
une pensée pour ce qui est arrivé à la
famille du président de la République
aujourd'hui dans un contexte totalement
différent mais qui ne mène nature donc
le vrai sujet aujourd'hui est de savoir
comment la République fait face à la
situation que vous avez vécu dans votre
cher avec votre famille
localement il y a 10 ans nous avons mis
en place avec notre association
départementale une assistance juridique
aujourd'hui probablement parmi les
premières associations des parentales de
maire de France notre association a
décidé de conventionner avec un
psychologue pour pouvoir faire un
accompagnement aussi des mères
confrontés à des difficultés et à des
tragédies parfois locales mais souvent
aussi intimes parce qu'il faut vivre
cette situation là en lien avec sa
famille et bien souvent d'ailleurs le
dispositif de bascule quand le maire
lâche peut-être à ce podcast vous le
direz vous le direz pas je respecte
évidemment votre intimité c'est aussi
protéger sa famille parce que les élus
ont des familles et les familles n'ont
pas choisi forcément l'engagement de
leur de leur père de leur mère mais sont
exposés tout autant ma question est la
suivante pensez-vous au vu d'autres
expériences
qu'il s'agit d'une chaîne de défaillance
individuelle
ou d'un système puisque vous avez
l'expérience d'élus une expérience déjà
riche
un déficit finalement de l'organisation
de la réponse institutionnelle des
institutions républicaines à l'égard
d'un maire à l'égard d'un élu à l'égard
d'une personne ayant autorité qui se
trouve confrontée à du harcèlement enfin
je tiens aussi à le dire nous avons
probablement dans votre expérience comme
beaucoup d'expérience que nous avons
vécues dans nos départements respectifs
du harcèlement aussi lié aux réseaux
sociaux à des groupes extrêmement
organisés j'aimerais éventuellement que
vous puissiez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez parce que bien souvent le
harcèlement se fait moins sur la
proximité puisqu'on est à portée de
connexion de nos collectifs de nos
collègues et de nos concitoyens mais par
contre on est à porter aussi de
connexion de tout ce qui fait
effectivement
qu'une république est aujourd'hui
bafouée que ces représentants notamment
les mers dans la petite république
constitue la commune
ressent de manière peut-être plus vive
alors je crois qu'il y a aussi d'un
point de législatif d'un point de vue
message politique à adressé aussi un
élément fort pour que je stoppe le
harcèlement et les organisations de
masse et parfois vous avez cité une
association qui est spécialiste en la
matière du harcèlement visé et ciblé
pour faire craquer la démocratie locale
merci Monsieur Joël guerriot
et puis madame belleritti
oui merci président
le 7 avril lorsque j'avais organisé
cette réunion autour de la violence
faite aux élus il y avait pratiquement
50 un peu plus de 50 élus pour la
plupart des maires qui avaient été
eux-mêmes victimes de d'une situation
d'agressivité d'agression de violence et
moi ce qui m'a marqué beaucoup Yannick
lors de ta de ton témoignage c'était la
présentation de ce fameux tract ou des
différents tracts mais surtout l'un
d'entre eux que tu as particulièrement
décrit tout à l'heure qui est d'une
violence extrême mais surtout qui expose
nos propres nos proches et je pense que
dès l'instant où nos proches se trouvent
en danger alors que c'est finalement
notre engagement à nous qui nous conduit
à exercer une fonction qui est la nôtre
je trouve que le dès l'instant où nos
proches se trouvent en situation d'être
eux-mêmes les victimes ou du moins
d'être agressé et de de sentir que
finalement on prend des risques pour eux
je pense que ça nous amène à une
décision telle que celle que tu as pu
prendre
et c'est difficilement
irréversible parce que on peut pas
mettre en danger sa famille ça me paraît
être extrêmement compliqué et c'est là
que je comprends pas la réaction de nos
forces de l'ordre je comprends pas la
réaction que vous qui vous l'absence
plutôt de réaction face à cette à ce
type d'acte qui finalement déclare par
de fait même une menace
inacceptable quoi odieuse
invraisemblable donc si tu peux nous en
parler un peu plus non pas de ce trac
mais de la façon dont ça a été vécu et
en particulier par tes proches
merci Madame belriti puis Monsieur
kerouge Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Maire je voudrais tout
d'abord vous remercier et vous féliciter
car vous avez le courage aujourd'hui de
dénoncer un sentiment qui est devenu
général auprès des maires c'est celui de
l'abandon de la part de l'État dans mon
département nous avons eu une dizaine de
cas pratiquement similaire au vote et
aujourd'hui et bien on a une réponse
extrêmement légère de la part de la
justice par votre décision de
d'abandonner votre mandat et bien vous
souhaitez déclencher une prise de
considération réelle de l'État je
l'espère que cela
servira en tout cas sachez que le 13
avril dernier j'ai interpellé le
gouvernement sur la recrudescence des
violences faites au mères madame la
ministre fort m'avait affirmé à ce
moment-là qu'elle mettrait en place des
mesures c'était le 13 avril dernier et
je crois que rien n'a été fait alors
voilà aujourd'hui
face à tout cela et bien cela renvoie
l'incapacité chronique de réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'État et moi ce que
j'aimerais savoir c'est pensez-vous que
la justice
des réponses à la hauteur envers ses
agresseurs
merci madame monsieur Éric kiero je suis
le ministre sur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Maire d'abord merci de votre témoignage
aujourd'hui parce que je pense que vous
êtes devenus un symbole d'une certaine
façon à votre insu et je pense pas que
ce soit facile d'être dans cette dans
cette situation après les événements que
vous avez que vous avez traversé il y a
plusieurs problèmes dans votre cas le
premier c'est que il y a une
recrudescence manifeste des actions de
l'extrême droite et de l'ultra droite en
France chez vous comme il y a pu en
avoir ailleurs vous avez rappelé à Calac
à Lille autour du bar citadelle ou
encore à Lyon la question c'est de
savoir si effectivement
on peut avoir trop de complaisance
politiques par rapport à ces exactions
ou s'il faut réagir parce qu'elle
remette en question la démocratie
singulièrement la démocratie locale et
c'est ce qui s'est passé chez vous
la deuxième point c'est que
effectivement cette
pas comment le qualifier mais cette
protestation politique extrémiste c'est
incarné contre vous et votre équipe et
votre équipe municipale en remettant en
cause la démocratie locale que que vous
incarnez et on en vient à un point qu'on
évoque régulièrement au Sénat c'est
celui de la protection des élus du
statut des élus entendu au sens large de
telle façon à ce que il ne se retrouve
pas seul trop seul devant les situations
qu'ils ont à affronter et manifestement
ce que vous avez décrit c'est exactement
ça c'est aussi l'histoire d'une solitude
par rapport à un état qui n'a pas a
priori répondu du tout comme il aurait
voulu le faire alors ma question elle
est assez simple selon vous
qu'est-ce qui a manqué comme réponse de
quoi auriez-vous eu besoin pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir continuer et affronter
cette situation ou pour le coup vous
vous êtes retrouvé seul vous et votre
équipe avec les conséquences qui ont été
évoquées malheureusement sur votre
famille et le débordement complet sur
votre sur votre vie privée
merci Monsieur kerouche monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Maire chers collègues ce que vous avez
dit est factuel
et le défilé de tout ce que vous avez
décrit jour après jour et beaucoup plus
éloquent que de grandes déclarations
parce qu'on a vu exactement votre vécu
et à cet égard on va tous vous dire bien
sûr notre total soutien mais cela n'a de
sens que si il y a des choses qui
changent
lorsqu'il y a eu la mort du maire de
signes on avait fait un rapport comme tu
l'as rappelé et on a on a dit plus
jamais ça
et là
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé finalement on
imagine le desservice de l'État une
préfecture une sous-préfecture bon il y
a tellement de problèmes on parle des
manifestations à Nantes à Rennes à Paris
etc bon voilà Saint-Brevin bon mais
d'une certaine façon de traite pas
véritablement la chose parce que il y a
une sorte de routine et ce qui est
devenu inacceptable c'est que face à la
question du droit d'asile qui est un
droit qui est l'honneur de la République
d'accueillir les gens qui sont
persécutés
et c'est quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental il y a un racisme banal qui
se développe à une très grande rapidité
et ça c'est une honte pour la France
alors ce qu'il faut maintenant
c'est un changement de cap de telle
manière que le moindre fait
soit traité qu'il y ait réponse et non
pas empilement des papiers pour vous
dire voilà on a reçu votre papier on est
on fait des on s'en occupe mais en fait
on ne s'en occupe pas il faut qu'il y
ait un coup d'arrêt moi je ressens ça
tellement fortement un coup d'arrêt et
ça appelle beaucoup de choses y compris
dans nos comportements aux uns et aux
autres que l'on ne reste jamais passif
devant ce qui est en train de se passer
voyez-vous j'ai été frappé quant à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde
s'est levé pour vous applaudir sauf ceux
qui sont restés assis
et
ça veut dire beaucoup parce que
ils sont restés assis devant la violence
faite à un maire
mais devant la violence faite à un maire
qui applique la loi de la République qui
est d'accueillir ceux qui sont
persécutés donc moi je voulais vous dire
un grand merci bon bravo mais tous ces
paroles n'ont de sens que si à partir
d'aujourd'hui cet après-midi on va voir
l'occasion d'en parler mais il y a dans
cette république un sursaut pour
agir dès qu'il y a la moindre chose
parce que la moindre chose c'est quand
même beaucoup trop tous les tracts les
papiers etc il y a des tracts on doit
réagir on ne peut pas ne pas réagir et
bien sûr l'incendie tout ça comment cela
n'a pas pu donner lieu à tes réactions
plus plus fortes donc je crois que notre
soutien est un devoir pour nous tous de
demander que ça change
[Musique]
voyez puis ensuite la parole
Yannick Moret
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues Monsieur le Maire je
voudrais très brièvement vous dire à mon
tour tout le soutien qui est le mien et
effectivement
à peine élu c'est pas sénateur j'ai
entendu
un ministre proposé balance ton maire ce
qui a commencé à créer peut-être auprès
des mers un climat particulièrement
délétère mais effectivement je crois
qu'en tant qu'élume malheureusement dans
nos fonctions précédentes ou dans nos
fonctions actuelles on a tous été
confrontés directement ou indirectement
à de la violence et on assiste
aujourd'hui à une contestation de tout
ce qui peut ressembler à une figure
d'autorité ou de réussite ou de nantis
et avec des personnes qui
souhaitent faire plier la République et
c'est vrai que c'est particulièrement
dangereux et je dois vous dire Monsieur
le Maire il y a quelques semaines dans
les Bouches-du-Rhône l'initiative du
président de l'Association des Maires et
de la présidente du département nous
avons une très grande réunion avec tous
les maires du département et
les sénateurs les députés mais aussi
toutes les figures d'autorité de l'État
et la question des violences a été
évoquée par nombreux de nombreux mères
qui avaient été confrontés effectivement
à des agressions et ils ont été incités
à déposer plainte et quand
j'entends
j'entends votre témoignage
vous qui êtes aujourd'hui à la fois
devenu le symbole de ces dévalences de
ces défaillances des réponses de
l'autorité publique des agressions mais
aussi du courage des élus
et moi aussi j'étais stupéfaite en
entendant le détail de votre témoignage
parce qu'on se dit c'est pas possible un
moment donné ça va bien finir par
s'arrêter je voudrais savoir
si vous pensez que
l'inaction est liée à l'affaissement de
la réponse publique et des services
publics d'une part et d'autre part
à votre avis qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
pour que la réponse soit à la fois
effective et efficace je vous remercie
merci Madame bien nous arrivons au terme
de la liste de questions
vous répondez dans l'ordre que vous
voulez de la manière dont vous souhaitez
naturellement mais vous avez seul la
parole
merci
pour répondre donc la liste des
questions il y a eu des personnes qui
ont déposé plainte et je pense notamment
à la directrice de l'école d'une part et
puis également à la présidente de
l'association des parents d'élèves qui
ont réussi à déposer plainte en fait
mais parce qu'on était derrière
qu'on leur a demandé à tout prix de le
faire parce que c'est vrai que elles ne
se sont pas des élus
elles sont là notamment la directrice
voilà pour assumer son rôle de
directrice d'école et l'association des
parents d'élèves la Présidente c'est
pareil c'est voilà donc là on les a
on dirait aider dans le sens où il
fallait à tout prix qu'elle dépose une
plainte et donc la plainte avait été
enregistrée tout à l'heure j'ai dit que
également que le collectif avait demandé
m'avait demandé à tout prix à ce que je
puisse les aider pour obtenir un
rendez-vous avec le préfet il a fallu
que je relance plusieurs fois le préfet
parce que ça devenait toujours pas et
la la veille de la dernière
manifestation
j'ai reçu un mail comme quoi il avait
été reçu quelques jours auparavant
simplement
qu'ils avaient été reçus par le
secrétaire général de la préfecture donc
et puis il y a eu plusieurs également
interventions sur l'aspect psychologique
alors j'ai beaucoup de chance puisque
j'ai pas du tout un tempérament anxieux
voilà donc moi tout me passe par dessus
voilà je subis sans sans problème
toutes les attaques toutes les
insultes mais là quand même j'ai pris un
coup sur la tête le jour où c'est arrivé
le matin même je me demandais si c'était
pas un cauchemark j'étais en train de
vivre donc quand je me suis retrouvé 5
heures du matin avec mon épouse en train
de voir mes voitures brûlées et puis et
puis la maison également prendre feu
donc voilà ça c'est complètement démuni
en plus à cette heure-là bien entendu
vous imaginez les pompiers ne mettent
pas de sirène donc je peux vous assurer
qu'on trouve le temps vraiment très très
long
donc soutien psychologique je pense que
ça peut être utile parce que c'est vrai
que
je le vois moi au sein même de mon
équipe voilà ça quand même pas été
facile pour tous les élus parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai chance d'avoir une
équipe qui est très soudée
il y en a quand même un certain nombre
voilà qui ça faisait peur qu'il le
vivait pas très bien donc même si
j'étais là pour essayer voilà de leur
monter le moral pour essayer de
maintenir toute l'équipe je pense que il
y a sûrement des personnes pour qui ça
aurait pu être difficile quand même de
subir tout ça probablement peut-être des
mères qui auraient peut-être
démissionner avant d'aller d'aller
jusque là mais bon c'est vrai que ça
peut être important c'est vraiment s'il
y a un soutien psychologique qui peut
être proposé justement pour essayer de
pallier à toutes ces toutes ces
difficultés
pour répondre il est parti me demandait
mon confrère ce que pensait ma
patientèle
un soutien total c'est vrai alors bien
entendu je pouvais pas tout raconter
parce que voilà
il manque de médecin même dans les
communes comme la mienne
voilà c'est c'est compliqué on n'a pas
trop de temps à perdre pour discuter
trop longtemps avec les avec les
patients mais il y avait quand même un
soutien important notamment au niveau de
ce projet de cada puisque tous les
brevinois mes patients aussi donc on
vécu toutes ces manifestations et quand
je vous disais qu'en fin de compte ce
qui était opposés c'est vraiment une
toute petite minorité c'est vraiment
quelques quelques personnes puisque tous
ceux qui manifestaient surtout étaient
en dehors de la commune et lorsque la
manifestation la contre manifestation
avait été organisée beaucoup de bruits
noirs dont des certaines mes patients
ils ont également participé donc
de ce côté là il y avait pas de
difficultés il y a une question
importante
sur le député
le soutien ou pas du député
mon prédécesseur
donc en 2017 c'est lui qui m'avait
demandé de prendre la suite
il y a eu on a eu quelques petites
quelques petites différences sur sur la
commune ce qui fait qu'en 2020 quand
j'ai décidé de me représenter il est
allé dans une liste opposée
que bon je voilà c'est son c'était son
droit bien entendu au niveau de jour de
l'incendie il ne m'a pas appelé
j'ai eu le droit pour communiquer
officielle qui l'a mis sur les sur les
réseaux
mon prédicateur était pharmacien
et donc pendant
32 ans en fait en exerçant un
Saint-Brevin j'ai eu des relations
jusqu'à ce qu'il arrête sa profession de
pharmacien mais j'ai une relation
régulière avec lui en plus je me
fournissais au niveau de mes fournitures
médicales dans sa pharmacie donc là le
côté humain voilà je l'ai pas vu
et il y a
deux trois semaines nous avons inauguré
un EHPAD un nouvel EHPAD dans ma commune
j'ai rencontré il y avait le directeur
du département qui m'a demandé tout de
suite qui m'a demandé des nouvelles qui
a pris des nouvelles de moi également
c'est Levi's président du Département
monsieur le député qui était présent que
je n'avais pas vu depuis longtemps en
fait ma même pas demandé de nouvelles et
depuis
pas un mot donc je sais qu'il est
intervenu hier on est question
à l'Assemblée mais bon
donc j'en n'en dirai pas plus
est-ce que ma décision est réversible
de mars et maintenant on a eu le temps
de réfléchir on a laissé passer voilà le
cap de façon à pas prendre une décision
comme ça dans
la foulée
j'ai bien réfléchi voilà avec mon épouse
avec mes enfants même s'ils ne vivent
plus à la maison mais enfin bon voilà
ils sont et
voilà maintenant
mes enfants me disent de tout arrêter ma
femme ne veut plus rester sur
Saint-Brevin et puisque pour l'instant
on ne sait pas la personne n'est
toujours pas arrêtée
donc c'est ce qu'elle me dit en faisant
mes courses si ça se trouve je le croise
quoi enfin compte il est peut-être en
train de rigoler dans mon dos une fois
qu'il m'a croisé donc plus ce qui s'est
passé le week-end dernier voilà on n'a
pas envie donc ma décision voilà je ne
reviendrai pas en arrière j'ai bien
décidé j'avais un autre projet que nous
avions construit avec mon épouse mais
qu'on avait prévu pour la fin du mandat
de toute façon j'avais décidé de ne pas
me présenter en 2026 ça faisait déjà
trois mandats
et donc va se projette nous allons
l'avancée et puis nous allons pouvoir en
profiter
les messages à faire passer l'exécutif
c'est vrai et quand j'ai eu le le préfet
le jour de l'admission j'en ai parlé
quand même de tout cela puisqu'on a été
un petit bout de ton téléphone je lui
dis quand même du manque de soutien
qu'on avait ressenti on s'était quand
même trouvé isolé
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'avais
marqué dans mon communiqué justement le
mode de soutien de l'État et c'est ce
que je lui ai dit il y a sûrement des
choses à faire
lui quand il est arrivé que nous vous
préfères
il aurait peut-être pu faire pourquoi
pas au moins au niveau de la
Loire-Atlantique une réunion qui
permettrait de se présenter de
rencontrer des différents maires j'ai
bien qu'il peut pas aller dans les
différentes communes
là vu ce qu'on subissait il aurait pu
quand même essayer de voilà que l'on est
un peu plus de relations ne serait-ce
que par des coups de téléphone des
courriers on s'est aperçu que il y avait
probablement un gros problème de
communication entre justement ce préfet
préfet et puis et puis les collectivités
alors que moi j'avais découvert que dans
d'autres dans d'autres départements
c'était pas du tout comme ça donc voilà
est-ce que ça vient de la personne
est-ce que c'est difficile à dire mais
quand je me sois quand je vois que dans
d'autres départements où il y a vraiment
une relation entre les maires et les
préfets surtout que on a souvent entendu
parler que le couple important c'était
quand même préférée et là ma préférée
peut pas dire que je l'ai connu donc
si j'ai décidé d'aller jusque là et puis
d'aller jusqu'au bout et puis devenir
également ce matin
c'est parce que voilà j'ai pas envie que
ça se reproduit j'ai pas envie non plus
que pour les autres mères je vous dis
qu'ils m'ont qui m'ont adressé des
messages et qui subissent aussi voilà
des violences verbales ou physiques
voilà je crois qu'il faut que ça change
et on s'aperçoit que dans les
différentes propositions de loi qu'il y
a eu enfin de loin rien pour l'instant
on en a bougé donc mon souhait puisque
certains dit que j'étais devenu un
symbole
ma foi voilà si je peux au moins
terminer
cette carrière politique pour en
essayant d'avoir fait quelque chose et
puis d'avoir fait bouger les lignes pour
justement l'avenir et notamment pour les
élus parce que on s'aperçoit quand même
que les contraintes sont quand même de
plus en plus importantes et qui est-ce
qui est à ce contact avec les
concitoyens c'est avant tout c'est le
maire qui arrive là en premier et c'est
lui qui doit à tout prix défendre toutes
les décisions de l'État et on sait très
bien que c'est quand même pas simple à
tout à l'heure j'ai cité en tout début
Lausanne je pense que ça va être
difficile voilà d'annoncer à certains
citoyens que voilà leur terrain on peut
plus les plus constructives on peut plus
rien faire déjà on s'aperçoit que dans
ces différentes lignes de de projet de
l'État
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il y a de la communication
bien pas forcément moi je sais que au
niveau de du pays de Ré avec mon
collègue mère Jean-Michel maire le maire
de Pornic on avait fait une conférence
de presse parce que on n'arrêtait pas
d'entendre on en a commune mais arrêtez
de bétonner arrêter de bétonner dans les
centres villes parce qu'il y a des
immeubles qu'est-ce qu'on construisent
pour essayer d'expliquer justement nos
concitoyens on applique on applique la
loi voilà on a essayé également moi je
l'ai fait au niveau de mon bulletin
municipal tout un dossier pour essayer
d'expliquer justement pour éviter d'être
harcelé en permanence ou d'être critiqué
mais c'est vrai que il y a peut-être des
manques de communication justement des
différents lois de l'exécutif pour faire
comprendre à nos concitoyens que c'est
pas le maire qui est responsable que lui
malheureusement il est obligé de subir
de faire appliquer la loi et d'essayer
de faire comprendre ces différents
messages de les faire passer au niveau
des concitoyens
la nature au niveau du soutien des
des élus au niveau de
au niveau de la puce que je suis
également le président de
l'intercommunalité c'est vrai qu'on est
relativement soudé et c'est vrai que
tous mes tous mes collègues mères
étaient avec nous et justement en
parlant d'intercommunalité juste
également pour vous rappeler également
quelque chose en vous avez dû entendre
parler que nous avons eu nous la ZAD la
fameuse date du carnet puisque là aussi
encore une fois c'était un projet de
l'État qui voulait implanter vous savez
il y avait 12 sites
qui étaient prêts pour justement
industrialiser cette zone et donc cette
date est installé et jusqu'au jour où
forcément s'entraîner vous imaginez bien
des des nuisances vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens qui habitaient pas très loin
et nous arrivions pas à voir de
rendez-vous avec le préfet donc c'est
pas celui qui est actuellement c'était
son prédécesseur Monsieur Didier Martin
comme nous n'arions pas à avoir de
rendez-vous avec le préfet pour lui
demander quand est-ce qu'il allait
évacuer cette ZAD nous avons décidé un
jour les 6 mères il y avait également la
sénatrice Laurence tu étais là et puis
la conseillère départementale nous
sommes rendus à la préfecture à Nantes
avec nos écharpes pour avoir un
rendez-vous avec le préfet
nous n'avons pas eu de rendez-vous ils
nous ont envoyé la police
pour manifestation non déclarée
donc nous sommes rentrés
sur notre territoire et nous avons
appris dans l'après-midi par la presse
que nous allions avoir un rendez-vous et
que nous avons eu deux semaines après où
nous sommes rendus à la préfecture
justement pour parler de cette
évaluation de nasale donc encore une
fois même si ça ça n'avait rien à voir
avec le CADA mais ça montre bien que
avec quand même un décalage voilà si
cimer une sénatrice une conseillère
départementale voilà envoyer la police
pour manifestation non déclaré c'est
des sous-estimations des menaces c'était
un peu ce que je vous ai dit quand on a
reçu avec mes deux adjoines le
sous-préfet et commandant gendarmerie
ce qui nous a dit en fin de compte les
menaces mais non c'est rien puisqu'il
nous a dit mais moi aussi j'ai des
menaces parce que nous a dit le
sous-préfet
et oui mais c'était on lui a pourtant
bien dit vous savez également avec
toutes les menaces qu'il y a sur les
réseaux sociaux on lui a rappelé quand
même quelque chose ça a commencé comme
ça donc pour la faire de sa mêle
pastille quand même c'était sur les
réseaux sociaux puis on a vu à quoi ça
aboutit et c'est ce qu'on a dit aux sous
préfet et il nous a dit mais non ça n'a
rien à voir voilà donc voyez les la
minimisation des
des menaces en fait on en va vraiment eu
l'impression sur
tout notre parcours d'avoir jamais été
entendu avoir été mis pris au sérieux ça
a été ça tout le temps
les réseaux sociaux une véritable
catastrophe il va falloir quand même que
il y a peut-être quelque chose qui soit
fait sur les réseaux sociaux parce que
c'est on a un
déchaînement de haine
avec parfois certaines personnes qui
utilisent forcément des faux profils et
qui attise la haine en permanence et on
se trouve totalement en démunis bien sûr
quand c'est sur le site de la commune on
peut voilà les enlever mais il se
produit très souvent des des groupes
et puis bah là bien entendu ben nous on
n'a pas du tout la main et là sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est c'est incroyable
cette haine et cette violence et je
pense qu'il y a sûrement un travail à
faire de façon à essayer de bloquer
enfin je sais pas comment on peut faire
mais essayer de de faire quelque chose
au niveau des réseaux sociaux et
peut-être est-ce que quand on porte
quand on dépose des plaintes sur ces
menaces ou ses insultes et bien ça
puisse aboutir à quelque chose parce que
là on a vraiment l'impression que tout
se déchaînement de haine en fait ensuite
ça diffuse au niveau de la population ça
diffuse au niveau de certains habitants
alors forcément en général se sont pas
tirés les plus cultivés qui eux prennent
ça au sérieux et puis qui peuvent être
amenés à passer à l'acte donc il y a
sûrement quelque chose
à faire
la justice comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure avec tout ce qu'on a fait au
niveau de du procureur de la République
on n'avait pas eu de réponse juste
information que j'ai oublié de le dire
tout à l'heure la première de la
République m'a appelé également le jour
de l'incendie
et puis la semaine suivante elle n'a pas
osé m'appeler alors que m'avait appelé
sur mon portable elle a appelé mon
directeur de cabinet pour lui dire qu'en
fait à la ouvrir une information
judiciaire sur les menaces
alors qu'elle avait pas répondu au
premier courrier on avait listé toutes
les menaces donc bon on a aussi il y a
eu un décalage
important au niveau de la justice c'est
vrai qu'on a un parfois l'impression que
en fait ceux qui
voilà qui sont qui sont condamnés donc
quasiment rien donc en fait les empêche
pas forcément de recommencer et puis
sans compter toutes les les plaintes qui
sont classées sans suite donc il y a
sûrement là aussi faut sûrement agir au
niveau de la justice de façon à ce que
il y a vraiment plus important qu'il
soit fait pour bien montrer que ben on
peut pas faire n'importe quoi on peut
pas dire n'importe quoi on peut pas
voilà insulter ou agresser que ce soit
verbalement ou bien physiquement les
élus qui eux sont là pour donner soit
faire appliquer les lois soit essayer de
faire en fait le maximum pour pour leurs
concitoyens
l'inaction
l'inaction publique je crois que je l'ai
oui
démontrer maintenant si j'ai je vous dis
si j'ai décidé d'aller jusqu'au bout
parce que j'espère quand même je
souhaite que ça ça bouge
donc j'ai bien voir ce soir puisque je
rencontre madame la Première ministre
Isabelle borne avec Madame Dominique
Faure je crois qu'au niveau des
collectivités il faut quand même que il
y ait quelque chose d'important qui soit
fait pour les communes enfin pour les
communes et puis pour les élus en
général on peut pas on peut pas
continuer comme ça on le voit déjà lors
des dernières élections municipales de
2020 il y avait quand même un taux
d'abstention qui avait quand même monté
alors que habituellement les au moment
des municipales c'est toujours des taux
quand même qui sont très très élevés là
on apercevait que le taux commençait
déjà à baisser donc et on s'aperçoit
également dans plein de petites communes
et je vois mon niveau de mon interco
beaucoup de petites communes n'avaient
qu'une liste il y a même une commune de
CorSec et juste à côté de Saint-Brévin
ou la liste elle s'est vraiment fait
trois jours trois jours avant le dépôt
c'était c'est vraiment donc en 2026
qu'est-ce qui va se passer et puis c'est
vraiment ce qui est important dans une
commune c'est d'avoir quand même
plusieurs listes de façon à avoir un
débat démocratique quand même voilà
quelque chose des échanges si dans
chaque commune il y a maintenant plus
qu'une seule liste où va-t-on enfin
voilà je crois que ça c'est important
j'ai bien peur qu'en 2026 si on veut pas
justement avoir des communes où il y a
pas de liste ou des communes et une
ville également d'une commune du pays de
raie qui assimile habitant qui avait
qu'une seule liste une commune de 6000
habitants donc je crois que là faut
falloir prendre en cause en fait cette
non participation le non engagement des
des citoyens justement parce que ils ont
peut-être de peur de s'engager et des
conséquences alors quand on voit ce qui
se passe je crois que c'est là qu'il va
falloir rassurer de façon importante
tous les
je dirais tous les citoyens qui ont
envie de s’engager bien entendu il faut
pas leur montrer de ce côté ce côté
négatif mais voilà c'est c'est important
voilà j'ai essayé de faire vite pour
essayer de répondre un peu à toutes les
questions enfin je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté pour moi c'était c'était
très important de venir ce matin voilà
pour essayer de faire passer un message
merci Monsieur le Maire
nous avons à peu près consacré deux
heures à notre réunion ce qui n'est pas
un regret mais plutôt une chance d'avoir
pu vous avoir et ok au témoignage
peut-être vous dire que
dans ce climat un peu général de
violence d'intimidation finalement plus
personne ne recule devant rien
il y a une urgence à agir elle concerne
les élus locaux mais elle concerne aussi
beaucoup d'autres sujets mais je voulais
simplement vous informer que dans le cas
du projet de loi justice nous
additionnerons très prochainement le
garde des sceaux et ce sera aussi
l'occasion de revenir sur la situation
que vous avez connue avec lui à
l'occasion d'audition de la semaine
prochaine
de façon à continuer ce que je veux dire
par là c'est à travers cet exemple que
avec les collègues de la mission et la
commission des lois continuera ces
auditions pour aller un peu plus loin
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé
comment cette défaillance a pu
être constaté à ce point là et vous
mettre à ce point là en difficulté
peut-être mettre d'autres collègues
aussi en difficulté donc le travail
continue en tous les cas nous voulions
d'abord vous entendre vous merci et je
vous souhaite une bonne journée merci à
vous merci